Have you ever looked at the shiny dome of
your grandfather and wondered, “Should I
start stocking up on head wax soon?”
Statistically at age 30 you will have a 30%
chance of going bald.
This increases by 10% every 10 years.
So someone 50 years old will have a 50% chance
of being bald.
Due to the genetic factors involved with baldness,
it stands to reason, if your grandfather is
bald, you too will have to face that demon.
Fortunately, scientists have pinpointed the
genes responsible and just might have a cure
for baldness in the next few years.
Hair loss is simply termed “alopecia”.
This refers to any type of hair loss no matter
the cause.
There are numerous things that can cause hair
loss, from medical treatments like chemotherapy,
to scalp infections and stress.
Countless other disease processes can also
result in hair loss.
The type we think of as “male/female pattern
balding” is known as androgenetic alopecia
(AGA).
This is by far the most common type of balding
and accounts for approximately 90% of all
male cases.
It’s also the leading cause of female balding.
Hair, like cells in our bodies, have a growth
cycle.
There are three phases: Anagen- the active
growth stage (80-85% of hair is in this phase);
Catagen- this phase is also known as the transitional
phase, when hair begins to stop growing; and
telogen- this phase is when hair growth is
completely shut down and the fibers fall out
(10-15% of our hair is in this phase at any
given time).
After your hair goes through the Telogen phase,
Anagen begins again and voila!
More hair!
This cycle repeats itself throughout our lifetimes.
In the case of AGA, as we age, our hair follicles
begin to shrink.
The result is hair that begins to develop
abnormally causing lighter, finer, and shorter
hairs.
In the end, the hair falls out, never to return.
They also tend to have shorter Anagen phases.
There are currently two known pathways that
seem to work together to mediate this process.
The first is hormonal and has been known about
for decades.
The second was discovered in 2011 and made
public in 2012.
It involves the genes associated with baldness.
At the base of our hair follicles is a structure
known as the papilla.
It is in direct contact with blood capillaries
that feed it the essential nutrients for proper
hair follicle growth.
These papilla have a large number of receptors
that allow certain hormones to attach to them.
They are called androgen receptors.
There is a type of androgen hormone in our
bodies known as Dihydrotestosterone (DHT).
Our bodies make this from the testosterone
that appears in normal blood levels.
When testosterone is aided by an enzyme (type
2 5-alpha reductase) which lies in hair follicle
oil glands, it turns into DHT and begins to
bind to the androgen receptors.
Once there, it shrinks the follicle, over
time, causing AGA.
Before 2012, this process was thought to be
the most important pathway to baldness.
In 2012, researchers at the University of
Pennsylvania’s School of Medicine, announced
that they had found the gene responsible for
male pattern baldness, and as a result think
this is now the most important path to your
shiny dome.
Known as Prostaglandin D2 (PGD2) it was found
present in abnormally high numbers of bald
scalps.
There are an array of stem cells present in
every ones’ scalp, both bald and hairy alike.
These cells get activated throughout our lifetimes
to maintain our hair follicles in good working
order.
The researchers found that stem cell descendants
that actually make up the hair follicles (progenitor
cells) were diminished in balding men.
The result is hair follicles that become damaged
over time- withering and becoming miniaturized.
After testing for the possible genes responsible,
they found PGD2 was the culprit.
The researchers then came up with an ingenious
idea.
All they would have to do is inhibit PGD2
from activating and your hair follicles should
be able to go on working normally.
They would create a decoy molecule that would
bind to the receptor sites PGD2 did, and thus
get in the way of PGD2 being able to wield
its unfortunate powers.
The good news was there are already numerous
medications in clinical trials that would
inhibit PGD2.
They are being developed for the treatment
of asthma and allergic rhinitis (nasal problems
caused by allergies).
All that needs to be done is to take these
drugs and tweak them to work on balding.
The researchers feel that a drug could be
developed in approximately 2-5 years.
How does the production of the androgen hormone
DHT and the presence of the gene PGD2 work
together to cause baldness?
The exact mechanism isn’t yet known, but
it’s thought that DHT has an upstream control
of making and/or releasing PGD2.
This is because DHT has already been shown
to regulate PGD2 in other tissues.
Until this new, apparent cure, for baldness
reaches the market, we are left with current
methods of treatment.
There is the commonly known topical treatment
Minoxidil.
This drug prolongs the anagen growth phase
of normal hair, and enlarges miniaturized
follicles gradually into normal ones.
This can take up to 12 months and you need
to continue treatment indefinitely.
Once you stop, hair loss will resume.
The bad news is that only 30%-40% of patients
will get the results they want.
Another treatment is the drug Finasteride,
commonly known as Propecia.
This oral drug prohibits testosterone from
converting into DHT, thereby keeping the hair
follicle healthy.
This also can take several months, or even
years to help re-grow hair.
It does, however, appear to work on a majority
of men.
Unfortunately ladies, due to potential side
effects, most doctors don’t want you using
it.
Another more invasive and expensive technique
is surgical.
You can have hair transplanted from areas
with normal growth to areas of baldness.
The techniques have become very refined and
have great success rates.
Bonus Facts:
• The average scalp has 100-150 thousand
hairs.
Hair is so strong that if you made all of
your hair into a rope, it could hold 10-15
tons or about 3.5 ounces per strand.
• Hair has the highest rate of cell division
in the body.
It grows at .3mm per day on average, and 1
cm per month.
Thankfully, each hair has its own life cycle.
If it didn’t, instead of losing hair randomly,
we would molt.
• The largest number of hair follicles you
will ever have are present on a developing
fetus by week 22.
The density or thickness of the hair on our
scalp will reduce as we grow.
The reason is because we don’t generate
new follicles during the course of our lives,
and our scalps expand as we age, leaving less
dense hair.
• The anagen (growth phase) of hair is different
for different types of hair.
The hair on your arms, legs, eyelashes, and
eyebrows have shorter active phases ranging
from 30-45 days.
The hair on our scalps have a growth phase
lasting from 2-7 years- thus, longer hair
on your head versus on your arms and legs.
Different people will also have different
lengths of time their hair is in the anagen
phase.
The result is some people can grow longer
hair than others.
• DHT, while an unfortunate molecule when
it comes to our hair, is actually very useful
in other areas of the male body.
It is required for forming our primary sex
characteristics.
It also helps during puberty to promote muscular
growth, facial and body hair, and helps with
making men’s voices deeper.